HANNITY.
AWESOME SHOW TONIGHT.
WE LOVED IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
HAVE A GREAT SHOW.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR I DIDN'T
THINK US.
>> FRUIT AND CONSEQUENCES --
TRUTH AND CONSEQUENCESES.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NOW EVEN DEMOCRATS KNOW THE
TRUTH.
JOE BIDEN IS UNSTEADY AND UNSURE
OF HIMSELF.
HE OFTEN DOESN'T KNOW WHERE HE
IS OR WHERE HE'S GOING.
[APPLAUSE]
>> MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU.
>> WHEN HE GETS LOST MID
THOUGHT, HE FALLS BACK ON VERBAL
CRUTCHES, LIKE DEFOURING TO --
DETOURING ABOUT HIS CHILDHOOD.
NONE OF IT SEEMS TO ADD UP.
>> WE HAVE A VERY RELATIVE
TERMS, LARGE PUERTO RICOIAN
POPULATION IN DELAWARE TREATMENT
RELATIVE TO OUR POPULATION.
AND SO I WAS SORT OF RAISED IN
THE PUERTO RICOIAN COMMUNITY AT
HOME, POLITICALLY.
>> OKAY.
AND AS THINGS DETERIORATE FOR
HIM, DOCTOR JILL'S ROLE SEEMS TO
BE MORE LIKE THAT OF A VISITING
ANGEL RATHER THAN A FIRST LADY.
>> GO DOWN HERE.
>> NOW, THE DEMOCRATS THOUGHT --
I THINK THEY WERE BEING CLEVER
BY NOMINATING BIDEN IN 2020 WHOM
THEY SOLD TO US AND A LOT OF
UNEASY VOTERS AS KIND OF A
FAMILIAR GRANDFATHERLY FIGURE, A
MAINSTREAM DEMOCRAT, NOT AN
EXTREME LIBERAL.
BUT ALL ALONG THE DEMOCRATS KNEW
THAT HE WAS GOING TO BE TOO WEAK
TO RLSZ THE HARD LEFT -- RESIST
THE HARD LEFT AND HE WOULD BE A
PERFECT FIGUREHEAD TO PRESIDE
OVER THEIR RADICAL AGENDA.
BUT THEY DON'T SEEM SO CLEVER
NOW, DO THEY?
IT'S ALL UNRAVELLING.
AND AS THE MIDTERMS ARE CLOSING
IN, THEY'RE REDUCED NOW TO
SPOUTING UNSUBSTANTIATED
ALLEGATION AND LAME PERSONAL
ATTACKS TO TRY TO HOLD ON TO
POWER.
BUT OF COURSE THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME DEMOCRATS HAVE LIED
AND SMEARED TO GET AHEAD.
REMEMBER, THEY TOLD US THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD HURT OUR
ALLIANCES OVER SEAS, BUT THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO ARE DESTROYING THE
ECONOMIES OF WESTERN EUROPE.
THEY TOLD US THAT TRUMP WOULD
UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY, BUT
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO NEVER MISS
A CHANCE TO TRASH OUR HISTORY.
>> THAT IS A METAPHOR FOR
AMERICA.
WE HAVE BEEN CLEANING UP AFTER
VIOLENT WHITE SUPREMACIST MOBZ
FOR GENERATIONS AND IT MUST END.
>> THEY TOLD US THAT TRUMP WOULD
HURT YOUNG PEOPLE, BUT THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO DESTROYED EDUCATION
DURING COVID.
>> I'M MISSING A DAY OF WORK AND
MY CHILDREN ARE NOT IN SCHOOL.
THERE'S NO REASON FOR THEM TO BE
AT HOME.
MY KIDS ARE BEING HELD HOSTAGE
>> THEY TOLD US THAT TRUMP WOULD
DESTABILIZE THE WORLD, BUT
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO HAVE US ON
THE VERGE OF WAR WITH RUSSIA.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS HE HAS
NO IDEA WHERE IT'S GOING TO END
BUT WE KNOW WHERE IT LEADS.
IT LEADS US CLOSER AND CLOSER TO
A BRINK OF A NUCLEAR WAR WITH
RUSSIA.
>> NOW, THEY TOLD THAT YOU SAY
TRUMP WAS GOING TO HURT WORKING
PEOPLE, BUT THEY'RE THE ONES
ACTUALLY DIGGING THEM INTO A
HOLE.
>> YOUR INFLATION SCOURGE HAVE
GIVEN AVERAGE WORKING FOLKS A
3.4% WAGE CUT OVER THE PAST
YEAR.
>> THEY TOLD US THAT TRUMP WAS
BUDDY BUDDY WITH BIG OIL, BUT
THEY'RE THE ONES CAUSING OIL
PRICES TO SPIKE.
>> IF WE TAKE A LOOK AT CRUDE
OIL PRICES THIS MORNING, YOU'LL
SEE THAT OIL IS COMING OFF AT
NEARLY 4% GAIN FOR YESTERDAY.
THIS MORNING, IT IS UP AGAIN.
>> NOW, THEY TOLD US THAT TRUMP
WOULD WEAKEN THE NORMS THAT
UPHOLD OUR SYSTEM, BUT THEY'RE
THE ONES NOW POUNDING A FALSE
NARRATIVE TO SO DOUBT ABOUT THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, ALL
THE SUPREME COURT IS RIGHT NOW
IS A REPUBLICAN-WISH MACHINE.
IT IS JUST THE ENFORCEMENT ARM
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AGENDA
WITH PEOPLE WEARING FANCY ROBES.
>> AND NOW THEY TELL US THAT
POPULOUS THREATEN DEMOCRACY, BUT
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO HELP
COMMUNIST CHINA BECOME REALLY
POWERFUL.
>> SUPPORTING CHINA'S ENTRY INTO
THE WTO IS ABOUT MOWER THAN OUR
ECONOMIC -- MORE THAN OUR
ECONOMIC INTEREST.
IT IS IN OUR NATIONAL INTEREST.
>> THEY TELL US EVERY
REPUBLICANS WANT TO CONTROL
WOMEN, BUT THEY CAN'T EVEN
EXPLAIN WHAT A WOMAN IS.
>> CAN YOU PROVIDE A DEFINITION
FOR THE WORD WOMAN?
>> I CAN'T.
>> YOU CAN'T?
>> NOT IN THIS CONTEXT.
>> THEY TELL US THAT POPULOUS
CONSERVATIVES PROMOTE VIOLENCE,
BUT THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
ENCOURAGE THE SMEARING OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHICH THEN LED TO
VIOLENCE AND LOOTING.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THERE IS
SYSTEMIC RACISM IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S -- NOT JUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S ACROSS BOARD.
>> POLICE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES CAN'T FIND WILLING
RECRUITS.
THEY'RE DOWN 300, 400, SOMETIMES
600 OFFICERS IN ONE DEPARTMENT.
HUGE SHORTFALLS MEAN MORE
COMMUNITIES ARE VULNERABLE TO
THE RISING CRIME THAT WE'RE
SEEING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS THE SHAMEFUL TRUTH.
BIDEN AND THE REST, I'M SORRY,
THEY'RE FRAUDS AND THEY'RE CRUEL
TO THE BONE WHILE PRETENDING TO
BE THE MOST COMPASSIONATE.
IT IS THEIR POLICIES THAT ARE
DASHING THE DREAMS OF COUNTLESS
AMERICANS, ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
ARE MOST DISDISADVANTAGED.
THEY MUST NEVER BE TRUST WITH
POWER AGAIN UNTIL THEY REFORM
THEIR PARTIES.
PEOPLE LIKE FDR AND JFK OR
RETURN TO SANITY WOULD BE NICE
AT THIS POINT.
WHO KNOWS WHEN THAT WILL HAPPEN
F THAT WILL HAPPEN.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE ON REDOUBLE OUR EFFORTS
TO RESTORE OUR ECONOMY, RESTORE
OUR SCHOOLS, OUR FOREI